For four seasons on the History series Vikings,
Travis Fimmel starred as Ragnar Lothbrok — father,
fearless warrior-king of Denmark, and the
bane of England and France.
In exploits drawn from the Dark Age historical
record, Lothbrok sacked and burned his way
across the North Sea until the end of Vikings
season 4, when he was captured by Kings Ecbert
and Aelle, who were intent on punishing him
at last for the death of Aelle's brother Aethelwulf
in the first season — and punish him they
did.
It was a pretty metal way to go out, too:
Lothbrok was thrown into a cage, permitted
to give a long, full-throated speech about
his inevitable ascent to Valhalla, and then,
in an astonishingly cruel move, he was chucked
into a pit of venomous snakes for all present
to witness.
It's not often that a television series will
kill off its very popular central character,
so the departure from the norm — and the
sheer brutality of Ragnar's death — came
as a shock to most fans of the show.
Why did it happen?
And was Fimmel as blindsided by the development
as Vikings' audience was?
Unorthodox as it may have been for Vikings
to do away with Lothbrok, history — actual
history, not the History network — has to
muscle in and take the credit for this one.
Vikings is specifically a historical drama,
with emphasis on the latter half of that equation.
The series draws its plotlines from the 13th
century medieval sagas of Lothbrok, a myth
of a man who was purported to have lived and
died several centuries before.
According to those traditional legends, around
866 CE, Lothbrok did indeed meet his end at
the hands of King Aelle and his cruel and
creative snake pit.
As for Aelle, he died the following year in
battle with the loathed Viking armies — although
probably not by the extremely brutal, also
quite mythical method of the "blood eagle"
depicted in the show.
Lothbrok's exit, then, wasn't so much scripted
as it was written into the historical record.
Fimmel's departure had always been intended,
because the program wanted to reflect the
generational changes of Dark Ages royalty,
so his character's demise came as no shock
to the actor.
In fact, he actually got to remain on the
series for much longer than originally intended;
initially, the idea was to have him die in
the first season as a more direct consequence
of killing Aethelwulf.
It's fortunate for us that the show's creatives
decided to give Lothbrok a stay of execution.
If he had died in season one of Vikings, we
wouldn't have seen him fake his death as a
Trojan Horse plot in France and pop out of
a coffin, or been treated to the sight of
the mighty warrior using an unlucky priest
for archery practice.
Really, it's a win for everybody that Ragnar
got to stick around for so long before his
glorious death; the only loser here is historical
accuracy, and it's not like History — the
network, we mean — ever much cared about
that.
All this is to say, don't feel too bad for
Fimmel; he may have lost a pretty sweet gig,
but he saw it coming, and has kept plenty
busy since his exit from Vikings.
And it looks like he's going to stay that
way for the foreseeable future.
In 2019 alone, he appeared in three feature
films: the crime drama Finding Steve McQueen
opposite Forest Whitaker, the bounty hunting
drama Dreamland opposite Margot Robbie, and
the Australian military actioner Danger Close.
The star has no fewer than three more features
in various stages of production, as well.
He'll appear in the comedy El Tonto, which
has wrapped shooting; he's currently hard
at work filming the amazingly-titled Die in
a Gunfight for director Collin Schiffli, and
he's slated to star in the movie Tau Ceti
Four for action veteran John McTiernan, the
director of Predator and Die Hard.
On top of that, he has starring gigs lined
up in two TV series: producer Ridley Scott's
sci-fi drama Raised by Wolves, which will
premiere on the upcoming HBO Max streaming
service, and a scripted anthology focusing
on legendary lawman Wyatt Earp, whom he will
portray for a familiar network - the History
channel.
All in all, not a bad slate of projects for
a guy who was plucked from the obscurity of
an Australian pool hall to become one of the
hottest models Calvin Klein has ever employed.
As for Vikings, the show has gone on without
Fimmel - but that, too, will soon come to
an end.
History has announced that the series' sixth
season, which begins airing in December 2019,
will be its last.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.